hier passiert ist eine industrielle
Revolution alle Wissensarbeit alle
Menschmaschine Zusammenarbeit kann jetzt
eben neu gedacht werden besser gedacht
werden und diese Technologie das
Potenzial sicher und und skalierend in
die Wirtschaft zu bringen das braucht
unheimlich viel Idee und und Wissen
Erfahrung die wir alleine eben nicht
haben können deswegen brauchen wir viele
Partner was man aber wirklich jetzt
erwarten kann ist dass alles was vor
einem Bildschirm sitzt gemacht wird das
wird sich jetzt in den nächsten Jahren
schnell verändern und dadurch entsteht
eine ganz neue Form der der
Büroarbeit wir haben es gerade in dem
Beitrag von meinen beiden kollegenin
jetzt schon einmal ungefähr gesehen was
was hinter ihrer Technologie steckt wenn
man das aber wenn ich sie das noch
einmal bitten darf mir einmal zu
erklären uns zu erklären wo ist
sozusagen der grundlegende Unterschied
zu dem was man jetzt vielleicht schon
kennt aus ich glaube viele von uns haben
chatgpt auch schon mal genutzt wo genau
genau ist der Unterschied zu ihrer
Technologie also es gibt zwei
wesentliche Unterschiede der eine ist
wir richten uns nicht an den
Endverbraucher ja wir Chat GPT ist super
geeignet wenn man irgendwie die
Hausaufgaben der Kinder machen will oder
wenn man ein Gedicht zum Geburtstag der
Oma schreiben will unsere Mission ist
wie können wir die komplexesten und
kritischen Wertschöpfungsprozesse der
Welt unterstützen also im
Gesundheitswesen klar Verwaltung haben
wir gesehen aber auch für große
Finanzinstitute und da haben wir eigene
Technologie eigene Forschung entwickelt
und sind aktuell das einzige Team auf
der Welt was in der Lage ist die
Herkunft die genaue Herkunft und
potenzielle Konflikte und Miss und
Widersprüche in Informationen äh
sichtbar zu machen und dadurch
ermöglichen wir das den menschlichen
Experten Verantwortung zu übernehmen
denn gerade für die Kunden für die
Industrien in denen wir unterwegs sind
da ist es einfach nicht ausreichend zu
sagen ah der Chatbot hat hat so gesagt
das wird schon
stimmen
sie haben mir diesen nächsten Schritt
wie Sie es nennen jetzt auch schon
beschrieben wie welchen welchen
Zeithorizont bzw welche Erfolgschancen
malen sie sich da derzeit
aus wir müssen Gas geben wir sind haben
sie vorhin schon richtig gesagt im
Beitrag die uskonkurrenz ist uns einen
Schritt voraus aber wie auch der Herr
Ministerpräsident gesagt hat unsere
Forschung ist exzellent wir sind hier in
Heidelberg sind wir umgeben von ein paar
der besten universit in der Welt und es
war historisch eigentlich immer so dass
Deutschland dass Europa in der Forschung
exzellent war und Geld verdient haben
dann andere damit und und da müssen wir
jetzt schnell Gas geben denn natürlich
ist ja nicht nur Microsoft das ist ja
auch Google auch Meta auch andere haben
erkannt dass die weichen die wir jetzt
stellen dass die entscheiden werden wie
die Zukunft aussieht und wenn wir es
jetzt nicht schaffen schnell genug mit
unseren Partnern diese Technologie in
die Breite zu bringen und dran zu
bleiben was Forschung angeht dann sieht
sieht schlecht aus aber eben damit mit
den Partnern mit dem mit der Ausstattung
finanziell haben wir eine echte Chance
okay das wäre nämlich meine Frage
gewesen der Bitcoin Präsident Ralf
Wintergerst hat gesagt das Rennen um die
KI das ist noch nicht zu Ende wenn ich
Ihnen jetzt richtig zugehört habe dann
teilen Sie diese Einschätzung richtig
aber wir spielen Klassenerhalt ja also
es ist nicht so dass wir da eine
komfortable Position haben auf der wir
uns ausruhen sollten mhm die EU hat im
Sommer einen sogenannten ai Act
verabschiedet der könnte dann in zwei
Jahren in Kraft treten das Gesetz sieht
vor dass KI Anwendung in bestimmte
Risikoklassen unterteilt werden und dann
je nach Höhe des Risikos dann eben auch
die entsprechende
Regulierung passieren soll wie für wie
sinnvoll halten Sie diesen
Schritt da sind viele sinnvolle Gedanken
dahinter ein paar Sachen ähm habe ich
kritisiert und eines davon dass wir
Basistechnologie ähm regulieren wollen
das haben wir noch nie so gemacht bisher
hatten wir immer anhand der Anwendung
also klar für Medizingeräte gibt's eine
harte Regulierung wie für viele andere
Dinge auch für Produkthaftung wir haben
hier zum ersten Mal gesagt wir wollen KI
als Basistechnologie völlig unabhängig
von der Anwendung eventuell regulieren
und das ist äh kritisch zu betrachten
aus meiner Sicht das wäre so ein
bisschen als hätten wir bei der
Erfindung des Computers gesagt so ein
Computer ist ja sehr
man kann ja viel damit machen auch viel
Negatives damit machen deswegen
regulieren wir jetzt jeden Computer egal
wo er steht ja das ist Gott se dan nicht
so
passiert darüber hinaus ist es so dass
das jetzt auch nichts Neues was nur bei
KI so ist Regulierung hilft immer den
großen den etablierten Unternehmen und
dass wir hier als wenn man sich die
globalen Machtblöcke anschaut hinten
hinter den USA und H hinter China auf
einem dritten Platz sind und dann die
ganze kreative Energie die die ganze die
ganzen Ideen die wir haben die wir für
Innovation bräuchten dass wir viel davon
jetzt gerade umlenken auf Compliance auf
Regeln ja bevor wir überhaupt die
Innovation gemacht haben das halte ich
auch für sehr bedenklich ich würd es
gern andersrum machen dass wir erstmal
Innovation machen und dann überlegen wie
wir das ganze regulieren denn wenn wir
jetzt nicht
mit den richtigen Ideen mit den
richtigen Menschen ähm ins ins Laufen
kommen dann werden wir überhaupt keine
Hand am Lenkrad haben werden wir nur
noch entscheiden können ob wir Kunde bei
den USA oder Kunde bei China werden
herris dazu passt auch noch gut eine
Frage die wir bei Youtube bekommen haben
von SM SM und zwar welche Maßnahmen bzw
Initiativen sie haben es gerade schon
kurz angerissen würden sie sich von
staatlicher Seite wünschen um den KI
standandort um dem KI standandort
Deutschland zu
helfen also da zurück zu quasi meinem
Punkt oder auch was der
Ministerpräsident gesagt hat Forschung
sind wir eigentlich gut auf gestellt bei
der Forschung müssen wir jetzt nur
schauen dass wir diese Konzentration die
notwendig wird helfen also es war so
früher konnte man KI konnte jeder
doktorant KI mit einem kleinen Computer
mit einer Grafikkarte drin machen was
wir jetzt halt brauchen sind riesige
Cluster mit Spezialwissen mit Menschen
die diese Cluster managen das heißt wir
brauchen hier eine ganz neue
Unterstützung wie wir unsere
Spitzenforscher unterstützen können auf
der Industrieseite müssen wir einfach
die Technologie in die Anwendung bringen
das was BadenWürttemberg mit dem
Staatsministerium mit F13 macht ist ein
super Beispiel sicherlich eine der oder
meines Wissens nach die innovativste
Anwendung von generativer KI in der
Verwaltung weltweit aber das ganze muss
natürlich auch in die Breite in den
Mittelstand in die Lied in
die innovativsten industrieplayer der
Welt reingehen also da müssen wir
einfach schauen wie können wir diese
Technologie auf die Straße bringen wie
kann eventuell die Regierung wie kann
der Staat
dabei helfen dass es Unternehmen
leichter fällt die Technologie
anzuwenden und da ist natürlich gerade
so eine Regulierung die auch so eine
Menge Unsicherheit mit sich bringt nicht
unbedingt äh die beste Idee mhm sie
haben die Person gerade kurz
angesprochen die es neben der
Technologie natürlich braucht dazu passt
noch eine andere Frage von YouTube und
zwar sollte Deutschland versuchen
Fachkräfte aus den USA abzuwerben um die
Innovation hier zu
beschleunigen das machen wir ja also ich
bin ja eine Fachkraft aus den USA wenn
man so will aus einmal hin und wieder
zurück quasi ja genau richtig aus der
kiforschung wir haben aber auch bei uns
im Unternehmen haben wir Menschen auch
von Microsoft Research von Google von
Google brain aus den USA nach Heidelberg
geholt das geht also das kriegen wir hin
weil wir halt eben hier diese Projekte
haben das wichtigste für diese für die
Toptalente ist sie wollen mit tollen
Menschen mit inspirierenden Menschen
arbeiten und sie wollen an den Projekten
arbeiten die wirklich die Welt verändern
und das diesen Rahmen haben wir hier für
Alf Alpha für die KI Forschung
geschaffen und wir sehen dass wir
Bewerbungen überall aus der Welt
bekommen auch aus den USA also das ist
überhaupt kein Problem wir müssen jetzt
eben nur damit das nachhaltig
stabilisiert werden kann müssen wir
diese Technologie einsetzen
weiterentwickeln wir müssen weiter
Partnerschaften
aufbauen mhm Herr androdis lassen Sie
uns gerne abschließend noch einmal würde
ich ihn gerne noch einmal eine Frage
weitergeben und zwar ist es wird ja
immer viel darüber diskutiert wo wir KI
tatsächlich einsetzen sollten wie weit
sie gehen darf welche Kompetenzen sie
haben darf und welche Regulierung es
dann auch geben sollte haben wir auch
drüber gesprochen wie ist ihre
Auffassung da als jemand der das in
Deutschland maßgeblich vorantreibt
welche Aufgaben sollte KI in Zukunft
übernehmen und wo sollte sie ganz klar
ihre Grenzen haben was sollte weiter in
sozusagen menschlicher Hand dann
bleiben was man immer beachten muss KI
ist ein Werkzeug also KI hat keine eine
eigene Meinung KI kann nicht lügen weil
die KI eben gar kein Konzept hat von
Wahrheit wo wir überzeugt sind ist dass
Verantwortung egal wie gut KI in Zukunft
wird Verantwortung kann nur der Mensch
übernehmen der Mensch unsere Kunden
Menschen im Privatmenschen müssen
entscheiden für was setze ich wie KI ein
und dabei Verantwortung übernehmen und
das ist eines der großen Unterschiede
auch von unserer Technologie denn so ein
Chatbot der einfach irgendeine Antwort
gibt und man kann gar nicht
nachvollziehen wo kommt diese Antwort
her gibt's da vielleicht noch andere
möglichen Antworten und wie stehen die
im im Bezug zu irgendwelchen anderen
wissen was es in der Welt gibt das ist
eine Situation in der ich quasi keine
Verantwortung übernehmen kann ich kann
einfach nur sagen ja kommt schon
microsoft wird schon stimmen ja und das
ist nicht ausreichend das heißt wir sind
überzeugt dass egal wie gut KI wird die
Verantwortung gehört zu Menschen und die
KI muss so gebaut sein dass sie
transparent und steuerbar ist